hello guys we're back playing the people
and Grandmaster bar Cobian I'm here with
Caleb Austin it's gonna be costing with
me today the stream then we're gonna be
basically playing players and taking
some questions and you know and talk
about chess in general so you can put
your comments in the chat and Kayla will
take a look and maybe see what the good
questions are you can ask me so the time
control we're gonna be doing is three
plus two guys so try to just challenge
that time control three plus two okay so
that way we can get as many games as
possible so we're gonna start out with
this game against 1576 and we'll try
some French maybe huh they're a French
defense you know see how that goes so we
have the classical and I will try this
sharp line today Devine over yeah you
know her variation so it takes I take a
heavy game against grandmaster bortnik
actually in the recent PDF for classic
tournament so assume I appoint you
should be three though right yeah my
opponent is playing very confidently so
let's see six I'm not sure if this is so
good this a tree before because now I
have ninety seven Niner five a little
bit of weaknesses you know to deal with
here
my main goal guys is to get the bishop
on f5 here this is very important okay
get the bishop on a five somebody wants
you to play the check periods check
Pierce we could we could play the chick
Pierce I like tying the chick beards
somebody asks for a good system against
the Scandinavian huh you know I'm more
of a default player guys and I'm worried
about d4 so I'm sure there are some
systems here if I don't know something
if I don't know some opening I just go
to chess base I put the moves in then I
hit the reference or online button and
then I see all the top games play like
my masters that's how you learn what the
best is you know but look at what top
players are playing so that's generally
what I go if unless I'm like it's my
it's my specialty you know so I use
chess base to figure out what's the
theory and what people play I would
recommend you just put the motion in
chess pays and hit the reference and hit
or online database and you got to go so
we caps on here now we already a pretty
good advantage here we got 27 coming up
okay eight this see Foursquare is gonna
be very useful for us so the question is
what do we do here so we don't want to
take yet yeah so we click we have six
protecting the night oke eight is coming
up and while why the a rook
why a rock this natural reaction but
there's nothing wrong with look f/8 as
well okay not a big difference here
to go this way I feel like we're not
really gonna be doing too much on a
queen side you know so I just want to
keep but rook f8 was absolutely fine
move to okay
okay what is he trying to do with the
same
I don't know
and uh block
can we do that
now we want to play six just fix the
structure look Fe eight we got 96 94
coming up
isn't
a six fixing the structure
and we just take someone wants to know
what you think about the CD 595 Bishop
d2 variation of the groom fold CD 5
sorry CD 595 Bishop b2 mm-hmm I like
that I play that system actually
sometimes I had a good game against Sam
Savion it's very good yeah definitely
it's a very interesting system it
probably doesn't give much advantage but
it's pretty good so Queen d6 now with
retic made on h2 before it's happening
let's see here should be a mate no here
get a look at this being made here
where is tomato let's get the scram
and Bishop g3
check
if it goes back to the background we
take two and if 9g three Queens III King
F 1 then just rooks III or someone yeah
now see I just played very simple chess
guys in this game I didn't do anything
pretty special just winning the really
the material and the game
okay natural natural moves enchants most
of the time the natural natural moves
they win the game so that's the idea all
right
um what can we say about this game just
you know French exchange typical stuff I
think this a tree before was just too
early you know you know I didn't
understand the position yeah I have a
good plan absolutely okay we have 30
people ordered in line waiting
hmm let's see here again time control is
three plus two guys not ten plus two not
five all three plus two that way we can
get games in before we move on anything
else you see interesting there any other
um well this is certainly interesting
somebody asked have you ever played one
C three a very off pit guy I like to
just put my pieces to good squares not
really very off beat yeah person so
let's see we get to play that groom
field line that somebody was asking
about okay so I will play the system
guys just to demonstrate to you my
specialty of Smith Slav Petrosyan okay
smith's love Petrosyan set up
we drop it
Bishop d3
this night on a six is unclear what is
it really doing there
do you have a profession besides chess
someone asks I teach professionally very
students I do a lot of teaching on the
Internet
yeah that's what I do just chess teach
and play
with a horse
and we take this is how I like to take
you just keep the pressure on the h3 to
stop all the bishop tree for business
and everything actually the night is
very badly placed on c7 people sometimes
gave to this position they don't realize
the night is really bad on c7
he's got no future now I just simply
play say Queen d2 rook e1 I don't know
he's trying to play b5 but I don't think
it's gonna work
all right
yes now we just say give me give us the
pond yeah
he was the part of the six
I guess he has to play one Bishop itthey
yeah okay i betray to strengthen things
up
take
would take let's see what the reaction
we're gonna get with this takes
a little questioning can a little
questioning on h6 you know let's see how
what do we get you know because we want
to induce some pawn weaknesses when
you're playing a blitz game it's not
important to try to play very deeply
it's important just to put your pitch on
good squares and make moves that put
pressure on the opponent that's all you
got to do in the Blitz game you don't
have to play very deeply if you're in a
standard game yeah you can try to think
about a deep block before okay
what is this before - okay so we try to
trade nice that's fine as you can see
again where this Knight is badly placed
on c7 closing the queenside seemed like
a bad idea for black yeah it's still
worse you know but now it's maybe maybe
it's more worse than before now I have
to choose between rook a7 or rook e1 I
don't know let's go to k7
now age six is still vulnerable I don't
know what is he going to do
they're giving us a poem now what's
going on line 6
check
take one age sixty is going to take only
four take their concern is a check in
each two ticks we have four
it was like overwhelming advantage at
mm-hmm
let's see let's see Caleb's gonna work
this or not
a lot of times you go for initiative you
know if it looks like we have some
activity initiative you go for it
tick
okay played this way now we have
95 I'm thinking to go here 95 check
up
for
we got this monster trick coming only
six you know
Queen there what is he trying to do it's
96 check what is he going to go there
that's the question
so maybe g3 was better than her for
actually so you have 96 nice equations
well I didn't think that this line was
that good for him but I can just play
even like a normal movie react we need
to add something anything I'm just
winning
I don't think okay it's Quincy one maybe
yeah let's go this way let's play a bit
more creative
Queen h4 go we got 24 seconds okay so
the time management was not that great
in this game okay we should be still
good
any blunders the Queen anyway and we win
okay so yeah this was a nice positional
again we got some small advantage and
get some idea so do we have any do you
think ding will win the World Cup I
think so
you know we didn't see like they tied
yet they tied today so I think I think
so yeah
isn't I mean I hope her job off wins
that'll be a pretty big surprise if it
wins but yeah and then they also have
this match for the 3rd place apparently
they're playing that's that's kind of
important for the candidate tournament -
all right
what do we have next here we have 39
players in the queue so I don't want any
unlimited time control games guys know
10 minutes games 3 + 2 once again is the
time control so please make sure you're
challenging me and 3 + 2 and we're gonna
get this game now going
against Nenad and not 1974 someone asks
if you're a good cook cook don't
specialize in cooking but I there's
certain things I can cook you know but
no I'm not a I don't cook too often okay
so this before is a funny stuff actually
I used to play this as white some little
bit familiar with it it's not that bad
you know but I will just play a solid
sister there's a girl before yeah it's
called Sikorski yeah we're not your boys
in our uncle Tonga yeah should be pretty
bad it's not that bad I mean it's
Yesi I already miss played mm-hmm
playing too casually and then this is
what happens you just should have just
just played a little bit more alright
let's try to play creatively here a six
ah it's okay it's dressed just like
Queen D 593 then just retreat the Queen
should be 596 yeah I could do that but I
don't really stop at this position I
don't think it's
okay what is it trying to do before I
just need to do something against efore
that's my main thing so I go here then
is what let's get the rope
so on a three-year playing Knight B to D
five nicey 293 pawn as a pawn and pawn
is a part killer
I think we've got a good position right
yeah I think my opponent should have
played a training center h3 now it's a
little bit uncomfortable
look
oh let's get the night rolling in now
what do you think Killip looks good
nights coming in centralization maybe
threes estrangement Knight c3 we
business we got a swell here - you
should be three Wow just taking bishops
no well this is hanging that's right so
let's let's do this first and kill it
Oh bah
putting pressure on that bishop now here
can you suggest a good chess book or you
can suggest several eyes yeah well I
depends what do you what are you looking
for another stick opening book mil game
book and game book I mean a workbook you
know really really maybe more
specifically what kind of book 92
I have 92 I have also I've also other
things I can try to do as well something
like this should be 5 looks interesting
I can also just take Queen yeah and
trade 25 rook FC 8 just just a
comfortable position
Plusle naughty - I think your defog yeah
it felt like he might have something
give it the coin
okay say palm is a pawn right mm-hmm
pawn is a pawn what is the best opening
book for 1d for players 1d for flesh
opening book ah
Brooke Brooke has a good books on d4 but
that's probably a little bit more for
advanced players yeah different
recommend his he's repair to our books I
think Nicholas key also wrote books
Nicholas key has a book probably yeah
yeah but again you know opening is
something that you know if you have the
Tres pace you can study bass you know
with the Tres based opening mm-hmm okay
what is he doing here let's see
26 I just want to double up my rooks
actually okay we gotta go a little bit
faster because it looks like we're
running low and clock 92 how does that
happen she blunders that Pataca
when we were held Caleb never will try
to trade ya never afraid to trade you
take back with a pawn of course of
course we take back with a plan to get
the pawn rollin in
push tux
and we pushed upon perfect
all right
and he resigned no c2c one winning the
game oh yeah this is an interesting game
I mean I allowed this 65 in the opening
but but it seems like it was okay
actually it wasn't that bad
seemed like why you should be a little
bit better because the center pawns I
know but it's tricky because I also have
the wing you know have a clear plan in
96 Roxy a night before you know mm-hmm
yeah I should buy a tree here this was a
bad move a tree or a tree but it's a
game you know
someone is really curious about what you
think about the London system its
playable I world champion Carlson played
against me it's playable definitely I
don't play it myself was white but you
know I think it's if you don't want to
study a lot of tier it's something that
you can consider playing it I don't
usually recommend it to my students
because I think in the long run you
should learn the theory but some people
play it that's okay this is already kind
of awkward he's giving me a tempo here
getting again some tempo so this is okay
for me wants to play
okay let's go d6 here
Quincy server just want to get the
pieces out here nothing super fancy
yep nothing fancy mmm because you have
played d5 instead of d6 there's no
reason you did well then he plays c4
yeah yeah yeah I didn't want to simplify
the position I wanted to have some
position like this where it will be
Rooker c8
six is good
we can get a 5 in
I would say if I was probably I wouldn't
have done in a full game because and I'd
be one night she turn right
I called her blood range it's a blitz
game so but maybe one maybe I don't
before before an idea yeah right okay we
can we can try so he's he's just playing
solidly this opponent is not really
doing that much to create things she's
just playing safe
ninety-five Caleb will try to trade
stuff up open up the diagonal hey Danny
can you bring me on when you go me too
yeah thank you alright need some energy
huh need some energy
Red Bull yeah guys if you have some fun
questions feel free to ask I'm gonna try
to do a meeting one here Caleb if you
work you want to do it no I'll play you
for it they really want to do it Caleb
Oh what's happening here
check it doesn't quite work
unfortunately huh what doesn't work here
king h1 he is if he takes I'll be happy
but he doesn't take help what do we do
now I have 95 97
I was 85 really was proved to be bad
yeah okay yeah I don't normally play it
five guys just just put it there why
didn't you play at the World Cup someone
asks what a cup
I didn't qualify guys otherwise how
would there not miss the World Cup but
I'm going to the ILO middle tournament
next week so you can watch my games
there it's gonna be very it's gonna be a
lot of fun all the top players are there
and I'm seated like 90-something there
so should be a good challenge a lot of
good players opportunities you know I'm
looking forward to playing the strong
tournament there okay I don't like my
position that much to be honest with you
Caleb after we get rid of this right now
at this point we kind of conceded that
that okay this for doesn't work
but the fact that he played a four it's
good now yeah we can maybe use this to
our advantage I'll come back I need to
speed up a little bit speed up just a
little bit
the server I will double up
I guess I'll play we should be three
Bhishma sooner
yeah we're here we're slightly slightly
worse but his clock is ticking down so
that's good sign so I miss he's not
comfortable can I go deep I get it
hmm why not why not change the character
of the position a little bit
- yeah he needs to take
now you're absolutely fine right yeah
now we're fine because now his bit
ripple is equally weak
I've got nine seconds
what do you do when you don't play chess
what are your hobbies
Oh what do i do I don't know let's win
this game first Jack just work let's
just work here at no time in Korea Queen
f3 he resigned a loss of time takes
Queen f3
you should okay yeah it works
yeah doesn't have check on da it won't
be SH before so yeah we got the night
after you finally in the skip my hobbies
are what I like to do I like to enjoy
some good food go out eat different food
with friends travel do traveling you
know new countries you know meeting
different people
you know sometimes watch sports
play some sports you know
those are the things I like to do yeah
when I'm not playing in tournaments but
most of the time I'm just busy with
chess lessons lessons lectures
commentary group lessons tournaments I'm
still competing guys not as often but
you know I played I played three
tournaments this year Gibraltar Classic
here earlier you know played for US
Championship three play the classic four
five six I'll probably have two more
classical events this year six thousand
one then November classic Asia and then
probably at the end of the year I'll go
to the world repeatable stew tournament
have you ever been to Poland someone
asks Poland yeah I've been there once I
played when I was a kid I played a
tournament there you know we used to
have this annual tournament Empoleon it
sounds do you so played it when I was a
kid yeah I would like to go back to
Poland I have some friends from there it
would be nice to visit did we had this
already but I never no no obviously had
a lesson earlier today my student played
the game yeah yeah yeah it's the best
way to play just and don't put the pot
on c4 here guys put the knight on c3
there's no there's no need to pull the
policy for any longer I normally play
nice III before it's no problem it's
just same same night f2 next
pray for to stop it
Cave
Letta HD or do you think yellow mmm I
guess in blacks playing so strangely it
feels like you should do something more
so what is night it's right here okay
okay here h3 is useful in let stopped
94/95 ideas in general it's good to have
the pawn on h3 in these positions
so what's your plan here to play an
eventual Avanti 5 yeah I might just do
it now yeah okay night
why not huh
you know it looks pretty good I think my
pieces are pretty well placed here
and it's hard to find a move for him Oh
probably the best move probably because
of Bishop e7 d6 right no it's play the
best mostly this is a good sacrifice
impressive it shows that the player
understands that importance of the dog
scores you know I think it just shows us
that he understood how bad is position
that's true that's true it's probably
just losing if you didn't play this it's
funny at night if your bears Queen c7
I'm gonna sack back on f6 and Glen Queen
h6
objectively I should be just winning
here I think but doesn't look like
anywhere close to enough yes scale if we
get it boom counter back counter
sacrifice it's always enjoyable when you
sacrifice and expose opponent's king and
then go for the attack so he has to play
a five check I don't know if there is
anything else but again it's a blitz
game so we don't need to go too deep
here guys
just take
and
okay well we have here six mr. Bates
them
yep that's a simple yep
all right excellent yeah so this was
interesting actually we break through
with e5 and you know essentially maybe
it's Bishop d7 was actually a serious
mistake because it allowed a five so in
fact you probably had to play 97 here
nearly 5 97 95 20 still worse but
manageable maybe but this justice 913
Bishop f6 and
Matt Mauro muy Cinco
okay so let's play d4 let's see what
opponent will play d5 so see what will
have goons can be the client or Slough
where the qgd here 93 and this line I
would play e3 here I know you for is the
most critical yeah
and now here for sometimes I like to
play this in blitz for fun a for for fun
you know it's probably not the best move
here but then I get this I think I
played this position in one of the
streams either yesterday or last week I
want to go Bishop d3 Knight f3
get me get my development you know I
feel like after f4 it should have played
c5 yeah that's actually excellent point
I had this exact position before
we come in tell us
with the queenside kind of clothes like
this f4 makes a lot more sense
yeah now we got a dream position the
Queen a server of the gist
really bad for blackmail
see six is very weak I have 94-96 ideas
I have to probably take this guy
as you see guys my moves are very
natural I don't really have to think too
deeply here or I need to do this and
that no most of the moves are just very
natural I just pin in right Bishop a5 I
have 96 and when you have a good
position moves they play by itself you
know you don't have to dig too deep in
ow
trade into a favorable endgame now
I wanna go to k1 okay seven four
okay you can have that can have that pot
no problema because on Rugby eight you
have Bishop d6 this is yeah now we take
now that we win the bishop after be so
and so and then we sell it takes from
table c6
again we got to make sure we don't
blunder anything but we're not going to
he's giving us a night thank you very
much II okay
all right
do we have any questions
who is the man next to her region okay
this is Caleb Gosselin he works for the
Chess Club tell us tell our audience a
little bit about yourself killed so they
know what's your rating like 2180 21 AD
and how old are you now 20 21 21 years
old young stronger almost master right
almost almost master would like 10 10 15
points away 18 18 points away from
getting the master and he trains I see
him train every day doing a little bit
of work at least every single day at the
chess club right mm-hmm using the books
and studying so Caleb should break 2200
very soon and and you work for the chest
helmet a little bit what do you do for
the chess club you I'm a chess associate
so I just helped run tournaments in
tournaments yes sometimes I'm only
streams on our streams and sometimes you
were arbiter right yeah you need it like
an arbiter for a tournament
so excellent all right let's see well if
you want to play me guys you get in the
queue okay and the queue is getting
bigger we got 29 people in the queue and
we got only half an hour left now so
take the strongest one pick the
strongest one not oh my goodness
GM any GM's here no no no it was the
strongest Caleb
sacrifice sacrificial master let's hear
it oh let's see suck sacrificial master
master sacrificial let's see so we
picked the strongest opponent well now
let's see what we got ooh should we play
that line sure somebody suggested this
so let's do it oh you should I mean you
could have played takes in 94
that's sure about that yeah Daniel
radiation yes not onion variation play
that against I have a game recently
ok our opponent is thinking it doesn't
look like he's very familiar with this
so that's good so that's very very good
can we take 22
the feeling is we should go h4 h5 and
mate here but it's not so easy you know
I really gotta get development first but
this is a favorable position I feel like
no queening for c4 IB should be three I
have so many ideas
now see four is coming okay Roxy one
here
Tigs Bishop c4 he's not really
developing his pieces yeah h4 h5
hmm
we tried to meet him or
it was like we should try to meet him
but like Queen age 695 yeah but he's got
some checks here okay this is definitely
a strong opponent guy so we cannot just
do anything yeah I'll just find normal
Jeff yeah even though we want to just
win but we just you know it's just by
normal chess
get the caso and get things rolling okay
okay first question is what is the play
against Queen d5 first question comes to
mind
right
should we tried
maybe he overlooked it
maybe he overlooked it
maybe you can play Queen a5 in Queen c7
[Music]
I shouldn't work
well we're up at rook then looks like
take right to get the seasick square
did the bishop
she's attacking our rook so we're not
going to blunder the rook protect
take more paths right Caleb
okay what's going on here
we could take
they treat three response hanging so
let's take
trickling g2 right game or consolidate
huh consolidate Caleb that's all we got
to do
so this was the strongest opponent that
was challenging us so we decided to take
on it for key we have a four key we can
just take the pawn and Kingi q okay
we're not gonna blunder medium one right
all right let's go here ooh oh that's
interesting okay about this Hey
grabbed what we have two rocks I should
be plenty rained upon but I just
yeah when you have a bishop like this
you're in good shape
Bishop issues cuts off tonight the
Knightly loses his effectivity okay
because the bishop only to is cutting
off the squares okay all right guys this
was a strongest opponent we had was
challenging us 2300 and what is this
rematch say it's just like he's
rematching us all right we got to give
it he wants a rematch our opponent all
right any other interesting questions
someone just asked what's your pre good
pregame preparation and in tournaments a
game preparation is just basically you
know look up the opponent what a place
create a little file see what games he
plays what openings to have an idea and
then you know I don't like to prepare
too much I want to just save my energy
for the game actually so I don't really
I'm not one of those guys prepares for
four or five hours before the game I
prepare definitely but not extensively
because you know anyway there will be a
lot of surprises and different things so
that's why you don't want to you know I
personally don't prepare that
extensively because then you're just
gonna be tired for the game but I know
some other people top gyms they like to
prepare for a very long time you know
all right so what we got here we got a
1648 opponent let's see if he's gonna
move so we got to get a couple of more
games in so
so someone asks if you're teaching
affects you you're playing level well
it's it definitely takes up a lot of my
time
but I really enjoy teaching working with
people helping them to improve so they
can see that they're getting better and
getting good results so I really enjoy
doing that you know I also have you know
really strong students Grand Master
students as well you know that I work
with and of course it's a different
training when I work with them so we're
gonna do a little check program for our
audience he requested to a little check
for demonstration here really play 9c3
well what else yes okay well we should
be teach them just even then we don't
need to play c6 anymore in this position
we can just play five and this is really
fun we could do that oh I thought that
was the kind of theory no because we're
not like obligated to do that we can
play differently as well but yeah that's
probably just the simplest simplest way
to equalize the game but our opponent
already not very familiar because he
spent more than twenty seconds so that's
that's good
okay what is this let's take let's get
the Tempe so what do you think the
tempos are always good right I'm always
reluctant to play eb4 in these
structures well we do the temples I
don't get it now he gives us a picture
that's just bad this is very nice no no
c6 Bishop g7 oh yeah that's nice
this is just a wonderful position our
Bishop goes on g7 castle
it probably needs to place III at some
point yeah it's already worse yeah
mm-hmm
slightly worse because I have the pair
of the bishops guys
rook e8 is coming up during crusher
who's the most knowledgeable chess
player today someone asks most
knowledgeable chess player from the
elite players merely players
I'd say called Anand know who would know
more than not on the but you know he's
been the top top player for such a long
time you know probably Anand let's go be
six we should be seven now but there are
other ways to play this position but I
mean this looks pretty reasonable there
should be seven putting some pressure
okay or is this is whispers three we win
a pawn so we give some initiative by
will by doing that so let's do this way
let's take
we're gonna do this a little bit
differently Knight takes Knight d5 when
you have two bishops you want to open up
the position guys open it up and then
start putting pressure
ninety-five Bishop c4
takes quintics
I mean we could have taken Bishop b5
just make the game how about that huh
little track motika mm-hmm on G ^ to
bishops guys that's why the ships are
worth more because you know you always
have this diagonal pressure this
potential okay so that's why we always
keep the bishops okay yeah
what part of Armenia are you from and
how old were you when you started
playing chess I was born in our Yerevan
Armenia at the capital and then start
playing chess when I was five years old
so
all right excellent so let's see here we
move on to another game this was a
pretty nice game you've got a good
position and press ok we have a strong
player 1900 let's see here are we gonna
play another checkbook or do you think
another cheque put a Caleb sure but I
like the fringe you like the French oh
all right
Knight f6 six
yeah this actually have Queen b6 this
Bishop III is a little shaky because of
Queen b6 we have put pressure on b2 now
Knight g4 comes in attacking the bishop
and now e-file we get a tempo so this is
pretty good for black
so
ninety-seven
we should be selling right
it's not very good for white to castle
here because I will go Queen c7 and then
I have B 5 B 5 I guess I have a 93 year
to actually 93 and 9f 194 take chick
chick chick okay I just go back I guess
it's actually I go Queen c7 will be 5
a 3/8 it seems yeah no I don't have a
lover
no no yeah before it's gonna be very
very strong
okay what's going on here it's Casso
first
in 85
we got before coming up
someone asks if you ever met Petrosian
and I assume he's not Tigran vote on
average what Tana [ __ ] wouldn't know I
was and I was passed away when I was
like 1 or 2 years old so I never had a
chance to meet him but I went to the
chess school named after him that's
where I learned how to play chess and
that's where my career started take yeah
I was thinking he might do this but I
did not think that this is gonna be that
great for him but maybe okay I want to
try something interesting okay I want to
give up a pawn Caleb this is just that
this is a positional sacrifice guys just
just to open things up a little bit okay
now we have a strong B file and after
Bishop e6 we'll have some good pressure
on him
[Music]
the question in this quaint said where
are we going oh oh this just like really
dangerous now so we got to get rid of
that defender right Caleb that bishop is
his only defender so we get rid of him
the night is still out of the game there
on the rim and yeah feels like we're
gonna have some ideas here check
we're gonna do this are we gonna do this
Caleb let's have some fun I don't know
if it really works but Jack
wait Wow
what is this this is not gonna work
come on this is ridiculous this is not
gonna work
check yeah I wonder who that is
Chekov
check
Oh
so many ways to win here how do we win
this rook takes we take
all right I just take this way
there were other ways to win it's just
simpler
Knight h5 is also a threat here that is
594
what is the score here four and a half
seven in half this is like old times
four against four yeah yeah Wow how they
do that what's going on here all right
let's get this clean here
okay
check
check out to the king and he has to take
bishop takes
wins the game or if it goes to e4 we go
25 mate
somebody asks who would win in a dance
competition you are been feingold big
dancer I know Ben likes to dance so he's
probably good at that
okay okay guys so what is going on here
he's we check and then take I mean all
right take just take
take more pumps we just take more stuff
take
well what is this rook
some people don't resign yeah
ah
yep that's the that's the game right
there another check perk victory okay so
it's definitely a pretty good pretty
good good opening to play for blitz guys
so definitely recommend you do that so
um
okay we're probably gonna get the last
two okay last two games
and I have some lectures later this
evening guys and these lectures were
going to be recorded and uploaded so
tune in for those lectures okay tonight
we're gonna record them and upload on
the You Tube channel so we're gonna do
theirs nimzo-indian defense mix it up a
little bit let's see I like painting
them though it's a good opening and
there are different ways you can play
this you know you can go for main lines
or you can just play normal lines
so I'd see cash could be 697
take
like seven
p6
so were you gonna play for a 5 or C 5 I
don't know yet it really depends on how
he reacts a little bit mm-hmm in this
position depending how what setup he
chooses if place f3 will be placed in
court because until you go for yeah yeah
I have to watch out for my d6 a little
bit here so that's something I gotta do
also playfully five in this position we
have issue profile idea census
rook c8 you know just solid and you know
with time advantages it's just it's good
opening for blitz you're very solid
you're a very solid very compact no
weaknesses you said black has an
advantage necessarily an advantage but
it's just a comfortable position to play
I mean it's got weak palms this is just
a pawn maybe we're missing something but
looks like it's just a pawn for now okay
okay
six
it's the queen e7r okay did
twenty-seven
look fel took eighty eight you know upon
it's more trades
take we're gonna take back with the
pontiff who want to and you probably do
want to right probably
isn't this is a trapped piece Caleb it
looks like it trap adora capital here
just sake with the Jeep on no I can take
with a queen and not hitting the road
even better why double up the pawns why
double up Caleb unnecessary unnecessary
right Caleb thank you
yeah I miss the ruthlessly got a look at
the whole board here guys the whole
board and now we come back to get the
bishi as well here with the check yeah
this one was just not that great
whoa where are we have two pieces broken
a piece yeah this is just hopeless
let's try to mate
okay all right when your head you always
trade absolutely okay okay guys and
we're gonna do one more game the last
game okay and we're gonna have a matchup
from a player from Bulgaria deep for
London somebody say you play the London
right let's play London just for for our
fans here so they can see that you know
I don't play the London but I'll play
this game guys this is what to call some
played against me so I kind of know the
ideas here so the point is you play h3
early here somewhere to have this [ __ ]
page to idea okay this I don't know
about this
d5 now we play 495 I think mmm-hmm okay
so you can actually let take here take
back with the e pawn so yeah this is
already bad actually I think because no
he needs to play c5 yeah but still yeah
it's it feels like we're gonna uncle
tonight only five we're gonna have some
good attacking prospects you know so we
anchored the night and it's like a
fringe the night is very annoying only
five very very annoying so we go to say
Ruki Juan takes we take back with f-pawn
its course it's like I'm playing the
French defense yeah that's like he's
playing the French but with a bad Bishop
seaport I think it's probably not a very
good enough
ceefor it's probably not that great and
we have a three ideas c4 is just
terrible
yeah the bishop guys the bishop which is
really really bad okay
eighty-five I'm not sure what my
opponent is trying to do so let's just
bring our pieces in okay ninety-five is
in a horizon here some potential ideas
coming up there I don't know it's I'm
gonna take this way I can take back with
a night take with an f-bomb think okay
yeah this is just the bishop is really
bad guys so if you place nicer now we
play H for setting up which idea Bishop
age 7 guys setting up the Greek gift
sacrifice Bishop age 795 follow up at
queen g4 o Queen h5 so now he has to
react otherwise great gift tactic will
win the game here on the spot
f5 Oh Caleb but that just creates a huge
weakness no huge weakness only six yeah
this is gonna be some very serious
consequences coming here 9 g5 attacking
one is 6 attacking on h7 I guess ok not
afraid
well we bring more pieces in right bring
everybody to the party now my plan is
very simple rookie 5 developer rookie 3
develop the rooks it's just gonna be
very bad for him
White has a very easy plan here guys and
we are going to break through and win d5
cementing the rook on e5
it's weird a position like this it just
plays by itself you know you don't you
don't have to worry about finding all
the best moves you just
if the bishop one c8 is not evil peace
if we take what is he gonna move the
night and take who's gonna move the
night okay so now we have to go here
now I'm thinking maybe we shouldn't have
put it on if I just win three three just
to make sure there are no tricks with e5
you know mm-hm
double up the rooks it's just that
weakness only six is just gonna be very
difficult to defend ah very tempting
right okay let's go here first skim it
double up the rooks on a target Bishop
is just really bad and now coming in now
everybody coming in some more pressure
okay
just want to take Lenny six
it's another pawn what would you have
bet on night see five that's five point
six I think yeah Bishop d7 a 95
we should deserve them my position is
pretty good maybe I can even sacrifice
the Queen there too you know like take
one c5 but yeah perhaps you should have
done that so what is he trying to do
here I can take another pawn here I can
just take another pawn here I probably
didn't play the best way here but it's
still good enough
1396
Oh Pass
that's important for key right there all
right excellent excellent we had a good
good session guys thank you everybody
for playing was a lot of fun and sorry
we didn't get to play everybody would
still have 15 people in the queue but
that's for next time guys and make sure
you tune in next week right next week
same time it will be unfortunately this
is my last day as grandma's in resident
and I'm getting ready for my trip to
Europe
to play an isle of man so there will be
another Grand Master coming in and he
will be playing so make sure you guys
tune in and play the next Grand Master
so thanks everybody for playing and the
questions and we'll see you soon bye bye